and anything i think the last final  remaining chance now is to push some  pawns in front of the white king  and pray and just hope that magnus gets  nervous  it's not going to work black just  doesn't have any pieces around the white  king  to create those threats but you have to  at least remind your opponent that they  have some stuff to worry about  and okay nakamura playing a defensive  move nakamura offers a draw  with that move and magnus accepts magnus  wins the tournament  magnus carlsen is the winner of the new  in chess classic the first tournament  he wins in the military champions chess  tour  finally the world champion is a winner  on the melt water champions chess tour  very mellow here and there he logs up  all right  teasing us a little bit there but there  we have the reaction wow huge  congratulations to magnus carlson  the winner finally we have to use the  word finally yeah  i mean it was really what we wanted to  see we all want to see magna